- [Voiceover] So we have
three different shapes.
We have stars, we have
squares and we have triangles.
Now we have a different
number of each shape.
So we have five stars,
we have three squares
and we have six triangles.
You don't see them all here.
This is just telling us how many
of each of these shapes that we have.
So we have five stars, three
squares and six triangles,
how many total shapes do we have?
Well, you're probably saying,
maybe I should add these numbers,
because I'm trying to find
the total number of shapes.
And if you said that I
would say you are right.
So let's add those numbers.
So we want to add five
plus three plus six.
So what is this going to be?
Well what's five plus three,
five triangles plus three squares.
Well five plus three is eight,
so this is going to be eight
and then we still have to add six.
So we're still going to add six.
Now what's eight plus six?
Well you may or may not know this,
and if you don't this,
well you could count
things out if you like,
but it is a good thing to know
just off of the top of your head.
So if you don't know it yet,
put this in your brain.
Eight plus six is 14.
Eight plus six is equal to 14.
So five plus three plus
six is also equal to 14.
Now one question you might have is,
well does it matter the
order that I do this in?
Well let's try it the other way around.
Let's try it again.
Let's try five plus three
plus six.
Instead of adding the
five and the three first,
let's add the three and the six first.
So what is three plus six?
Well that's going to be nine.
Then we're going to have five plus nine.
Five plus nine.
Well, once again, if you know
that, you'll know it's 14,
If you don't know that,
that's another good thing
to put in your brain and just to know.
Five plus nine is equal to 14.
If you don't know that,
and you don't believe me
take some pebbles out and five pebbles
and then nine more, and you'll see
that when you add them
together, you get to 14.
But this is just a good thing
for you to know in your brain.
And you could have done
it the other way around.
You could have added five and six first,
you get 11 plus three
would have also been 14.
Either way, you have 14 total shapes.